we asked the BuzzFeed Community to send  us their secret menu items and we're  going to eat them never tried the secret  menu before also it's a secret so like  how would I know oh  [Music]  I'm holding it there's nothing to hate  about those this is like a grilled  cheese sandwich but with meat if  somebody bought me this and I had to pay  for it I'd be and irate right now  this is like the inside of your mouth  after you when you're eating in and out  this is the inside my stomach just  growled in like happiness it's good A  Stoner walked up to the cashier and it  out and he was like I want I want a  Patty on my fries and the guy was like  don't you just want a burger and fries  he's like no no no no on it